Fifteen years and these lights still work
Oh yeah? Let me show you how to light it up
Yeah, let's just take this one week at a time
I think things will turn around this Christmas
No, no, no. He wants a PS4
How about a PS4?
PS4! PS4! PS4!
Great deals on PS4 now
I thought the Seahawks were like, injured, or terrible
The kid's all alone in there
Let's sack 'em and take the NFC West!
OWWW!
They've done it!
The Seahawks are going to the Super Bowl!
We are the 12th man! We are so important
We rattle the other team
Ow! Ow! Wait a minute, I'm a professional quarterback
This doesn't affect me
[We're basically on the team!]
Thirsty for more?
Whiff!
It's over Wilson, you've got no football team
BANG!
Christmas is a distraction